okay it is time for hatred mail what is
hatred mail
this is hey tree Amell so what if the
president's been accused of sexual
harassment 15 times or that he paid hush
money to a porn star
at least he never wore a tan suit
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom that's right Patriot
mail is when a professional voice-over
artist interprets the hate mail that I
get and there is a lot of interpretation
to be done with this week's hatred mail
take a listen to it
David Parkman liar liar liar liar liar
liar you are very sick and disgusting
David Park man shame on you the weak
apologist Jew total betta pansy what a
shameful how our David you shame the
name David wine and play the victim
Bader yeah this whole bata thing has
really a a picked up and I actually
don't know when it started exactly like
did beta I I don't think it stemmed from
the Trump presidency although I think it
was significantly popularized I think
the whole alpha male beta male thing has
maybe surfaced in the same vein as the
sort of soy boy ad homonyms of the left
but I don't even maybe men's rights
activism has a role to play in this
whole alpha beta thing but it's all
incredibly stupid and wildly immature
which makes it perfect for hatreds send
a middle finger salute to the hatreds by
becoming a member on our website and
using the coupon code hey tree at forty
ok the coupon code hey tree at forty
which I'll spell for you in a moment
saves you forty percent off of any
membership and it's a direct signal it's
a message to the hatreds that they can
use whatever homophobic slurs they want
in their messages to me
they can use whatever anti-semitic slurs
they want they can use whatever
emasculating terms they think will
trigger me that they want you are not
going to be bullied and you are actually
going to say I support progressive
independent media like the david pakman
show and using the coupon code hey tree
at 40 when you become a member
sends exactly that message the coupon
code is spelled h 80
RI o t 4 0 and it'll save you 40% and
make many hatreds cry at the impotence
of their attacks on me